werden bei uns auftritte oder texte von
missliebigen künstlern gecancelt also
abgesagt beziehungsweise gelöscht
beispiel lisa eckhard die kabarettistin
ist für viele linke ein rotes tuch und
wurde deshalb von einem festival in
hamburg ausgeladen beispiel dieter nuhr
für die deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft
schriebe einen text setzte sich kritisch
mit der klimabewegung und greta thunberg
auseinander
es folgte ein shitstorm in den sozialen
medien der text wurde zeitweise entfernt
ist das noch meinungsfreiheit muss nicht
gerade kunst und kultur möglichkeiten
schaffen um ins gespräch zu kommen
du musst man unbequeme meinungen
aushalten können dienste der kreativen
branche
die erste frage die ich mir dabei stelle
ist was es unbequem
also wo fängt unbequem an wo hört und
bequem auf das ist ja ein sehr diffuse
begriff auch und ja was in der
fragestellung eigentlich schon auch mit
drin ist ist auch die antwort
meinungsfreiheit also es geht ja
letztendlich ein höchstes gut für mich
in unserer gesellschaft ist einfach nach
wie vor die meinungsfreiheit und dass
wir in einer demokratischen gesellschaft
leben wo wirklich viele phänomene
auftauchen und wir versuchen da
irgendwie einen guten konsens zu bringen
und was ich für mich ganz wichtig finde
ist dass die kunst sei es jetzt kabarett
sei es theater tanz fotografie film
fernsehen was auch immer dass das lebt
das ist ja eine bestimmte form also es
ist ja eine eine kunstform also eine art
von format es ist ja nie alles so eins
zu eins es lebt von übertreibung
es lebt von provokation es lebt von
vielleicht auch gefälligkeit oder so
also kunst als solche ist ja wahnsinnig
reichhaltig in seiner form und deswegen
finde ich auch man darf immer ins
extreme auch gehen so also da ist
natürlich die frage rechts lebens wie
weit wie weit geht es das ist das stück
das ist richtig und er persönlich die
grenze wie würdest du das hinsehen am
set jetzt wenn wenn du beim beim
schauspielern bist und ihr habt ein
drehtag gibt es auch kollegen wo du
manchmal denkst oh wow der kommentar
geht aber ein bisschen zu weit
also
das sind auch oder also dass das ist
ganz das ist jetzt für mich ein bisschen
schwierig zu sagen dass ich weil ich das
jetzt gar nicht so aus meiner erfahrung
richtig schildern könnte ich könnte es
dann eigentlich nur immer so theoretisch
sein weil wir irgendwie da immer alle
sehr freiheitsliebend so aufgestellt
sind so wie ich mich jetzt so mit meinen
meinen kollegen da irgendwie sogleich
stellen würde
aber ich würd ich würde schon natürlich
irgendwie hoffen dass ich dann was sage
wenn es mir zu sehr in eine rechte
richtung gehe oder so dass ich dinge
dass ich dann sage das finde ich jetzt
das überschreitet einfach eine grenze
das ist nicht in ordnung und das das
passt einfach auch nicht in unser
heutiges gesellschaftsbild weil es
vielleicht einfach plötzlich strömungen
auslöst die uns nicht mehr gerecht
werden und die sehr einseitig sind und
einen viel zu großen einfluss nehmen
weil man muss sagen diese karte hat es
natürlich schon faustdick navi sagt ja
schon krasse sachen manche kennen die
jetzt vielleicht auch haben wir nicht
direkt auf den schirm aber ein beispiel
zum beispiel ein beispiel zum beispiel
das auch schön werden abschiebungen dann
umweltfreundlich zu fuß und ohne
proviant flüchtlinge oder plastik oder
asylant ich will kein müll am strand das
ist zum beispiel ein satz den manche
leute wahnsinnig lustig finden und sich
dabei sehr lange amüsieren können
wie geht es dir dabei minuten hört ist
er für dich lustig ist es humor ist es
muss eine grenze überschritten worden
es ist für mich überzogen weil natürlich
menschen und gegenstände einfach
gleichgesetzt werden und entwertet
werden
aber es hat in dieser überziehung
wiederum ja die art von provokation
darüber nachzudenken also es ist auch
finde ich für mich bist sowas auch ein
anreiz wirklich darüber nachzudenken wie
gehen wird denn eigentlich mit diesem
phänomen auch wirklich um und von daher
finde ich das eigentlich kann das zu
stehen lassen
du kannst es besteht überhaupt nicht so
schwer
ich finde dass weder lustig noch ist es
geschmackvoll
ich finde es sogar menschenfeindlich und
ich finde die kunst darf nicht alles und
ich finde wir im tarnen uns manchmal
oder auch satire darf alles das ist so
etwas was man gern hart wenn sie darf
nicht alles wir dürfen wir haben wir
sehen menschen leben gehen in diesen
gewässern wir sehen
menschen auf der flucht ich finde
darüber witze zu machen finde ich fehl
am platz und das sind auch noch witze
die ich nicht intelligent findet nicht
zum nachdenken anregen sondern das ist
so ein schenkelklopfer niveau und ich
finde wenn wir auf so niveau gehen mit
mit schicksalen mit rassismus mit
antisemitismus wie lisa ecker das ja
auch gemacht hat dann finde ich es
richtig dass wir sagen nein kunst dieser
art hat keinen platz es ist keine kunst
weil es es ist nur beleidigend und es
ist im zweifel rassistisch antisemitisch
oder geschmacklos also ich finde es ganz
interessant dass auch mit zweierlei maß
gemessen wird ich kannte das ganz
spannend die frage gestellt hast wie
viel last ein bezug von rechts und von
links und ich glaube das kommt immer auf
den rezipienten an und es geht natürlich
auch immer darum ja auf welcher seite
man persönlich dabei steht und ich finde
alle drei figuren die gerade gezeigt
worden
da erlebe ich kein cancel oder oder
etwas in die richtung
also ich sage immer so ich sage ich sage
mir nie so ganz gut für den hintergrund
auch bei frank hat natürlich weil sie
eingeladen war in hamburg zu spielen und
da wurde erst vom veranstalter abgesagt
weil er zu viel druck von links bekamen
er hat er gesagt oh nee da lade ich sie
lieber wieder raus bevor ich jetzt hier
irgendwie für ärger sorgen das ist so
der ich glaube da ein bisschen werden
dieses bisschen genauer bleiben sondern
es war ja so dass sie auch angegriffen
worden ist und dass das ein
sicherheitsrisiko dargestellt hat also
das war gar nicht so haben wir zwar gar
nicht so dass sie mit vorauseilendem
gehorsam das passiert natürlich ganz gut
ins bild aber ich möchte dort trotzdem
noch mal sagen sowohl bei frauen als
auch mal dieter nuhr habe ich null das
gefühl dass die nicht zu wort kommen
also da wurde überhaupt wissen gecancelt
im gegenteil die geben große interesse
werden interviewt hat so die finden
statt die werden besprochen was hat das
mit cancel also also für mich ist es das
gegenteil davon also ich finde das ist
natürlich ja eben auch genau hinzugucken
und daneben auch selber zu entscheiden
finde ich das witzig finde ich dass wir
das lustig finde ich das witzig obwohl
es rassistisch ist also es ist ja so ein
breites feld und das ist ja bei
machinarium wenn du das hören die wir
uns bewegen beispielsweise ich finde es
grundfalsch grundfalsch menschen mit
müll zu vergleichen aber ich habe diese
sätze auch schon von linke ecke gehört
das heißt für mich verläuft die
trennlinie nicht da
danach dass ich sage ist das links ist
das recht sondern ist das rassistisch
ist es sexistisch ist antisemit
tisch und ich finde die art und weise
wie frau eckert daneben auch erklärt
dass wenn juden nicht über ihre witze
lachen die keinen humor haben oder die
darüber lachen dass wenigstens verstehen
würden das ist glaube ich zu
kleingeistig trotzdem finde ich obwohl
ich überhaupt nicht der meinung bin von
frau eckert dass wir alles dafür tun
müssen diese meinung zuzulassen du hast
gerade die kunst angesprochen also die
kunst die eller wo man sich die
erlaubnis holen muss die wird ja
irgendwann zu staatskunst und das ist ja
ein ganz dunkles kapitel in unserem in
unserer geschichte sei nicht in die
kunden erwartet es lägen keine autos
fahren hinein und deswegen seinen
kollegen das passiert ja gerade wie
diskutieren das ja auch aber natürlich
karikatur satire über zeichnet eben auch
es ist vom grundgesetz gedeckt die
meinungsfreiheit die kunstfreiheit und
an diesem ist auch nicht als es vom hs
verboten werden soll
das ist genau wichtiger punkt ich finde
aber wir brauchen ein korrektiv das uns
beim teil dieser eckert bleiben das kann
dann aus der linken ecke ist da finde
ich es manchmal schwierig weil die
glaube ich ein sehr großen einfluss
korrigieren sie mich auf die kunst oder
künstlerszene hat und das teilweise für
mich so eine bewegung ist und da heißt
wir müssen weltoffen sein
das geht aber nicht das geht aber nicht
dass gibt aber das passiert ruhig seien
gar nicht so toll am 11 weniger
weltoffen als man denkt
in dem fall war ich froh dass irgendeine
art korrektiv gegriffen hat ich glaube
aber dass es einfach nur sein muss dass
wir uns immer wieder hinterfragen das
wissen was löst es ausgeht dass befeuern
wir damit vielleicht gedanken die wir
gar nicht befeuern wollen
die bewertung ist es lustig oder nicht
lasse ich es wirklich jeden einzelnen
ich finde tatsächlich die meisten
kabarettisten nicht so lustig habe damit
bin ich mal ran um ich muss mehr lachen
wenn jemand kurz hin fällt aber auch
dass es vielleicht schwenker humor
stimmen also aber jetzt zumindest bin
ich sollten wir es immer wieder
hinterfragen was die kunst mit einem
machen kann weil die kunst kann ganz
viele positive gedanken auslösen sie
kann aber auch weil sie oft in großen
einfluss hat auch gefährliche gedanken
auslösen und bevor wir das auslösen
sollten wir uns dieser frage schon mal
aber ich glaube die kunst die wir
unterdrücken dies am gefährlichsten und
natürlich ist sozusagen auch dieses
canceln nicht losgelöst zu verstehen
auch von den social media debatten und
den mut debatten die damit einhergehen
und wo das hoch gekocht wird und wenn es
dann so weit kommt dass die menschen
eben auch aufträge verlieren obwohl sie
nachweislich nicht antisemitisch sind
wenn sie antisemitisch werden über das
auch ein fall für die sicherheit
das haben nicht wie zu bewerten wir
können das eine kann das gut verstehen
aber ich sage mal eine angepasste das
als eigentlich simon genau wie handys
fuhren die diebe geworden sind und wenn
die die betroffen sind sagen es ist
antisemitisch wie im fall dieser ecke
passiert
[Musik]